I can't pay rent with the things once a
pumpkin and these are Guardian kind
they're not worth it in Asgard those
coins these coins are worth a gazillion
human dollars okay there's a gazillion
you're rich that's been doing silly
including it though no one will exchange
the go to the market set up a store and
right yeah
as guardian where previously owned by
four I'm a celebrity that will sell like
hotcakes you might need to think about
getting a getting a job job yeah yeah I
have a job Joe my job is I saved the
planet yet maybe you should get a job I
have a job really getting the machine
with the words that come out of it all
this is knowledge knowledge is power
no it's not knowledge is not power
that's power the brain is a muscle and
that's the muscle and that's a muscle
there you're all muscles this is all
muscle so I am covered in brains and has
more brains than you so do you think
maybe we could just think that we need a
servant I don't think we can get a
surgeon get a servant we can today we
didn't get also getting a servant
Marvel's Doctor Strange on digital and
blu-ray
you